[Music]
let's talk about
problematic youtubers like who in this
room
no no no no no what do you want to talk
[ __ ] about tiff
i feel like i should be because i'll get
more views no the algorithm's been
[ __ ] with me
well okay so this story is about these
twins
and they're named ellen and alex oh
i know do you know who they are i heard
the story do you know them tim
no were you stoked and they stoked
and so it's these guys they have 4.80
something million
subscribers on youtube congrats couple
cuties what do they do
music this is them celebrating 25 mil i
think on tick tock or something
anyway rub it in my face
they're way more younger wait way
younger more successful than you sorry
oh damn burn oh debatable
well tick tock is getting banned too so
i mean they should probably ha ha
ha ha jokes on you i mean four mil on
youtube though
they're gonna go on reels now but i mean
look at their skin do they always dress
the same
i don't know i don't think these guys do
they do dance
tim you're the only one that knows this
these twins right what do they do dance
i i don't know them i
i heard this story that she's about to
tell the story the story what do they do
just youtube [ __ ] okay like youtube type
of stuff like challenges
and pranking pranks stuff like that
so the reason why they're in trouble is
because
in october of last year these guys they
decided that it was a good idea
to dress in all black carry duffel bags
and pretend as if they just robbed a
bank and call an
uber driver and get them to drive them
away but the driver refused and a
witness
even said that they believed that they
were actually trying to
carjack the uber driver so cops were
called to the scene
and then you want that cops called yeah
and then once they
arrived and then they they explained
what they were doing so then they were
it's a prank bro they were really yeah
it's just a prank bro so they were
released
but then two hours later they did a
similar prank
and uh this was in uci
on the campus and that's when they the
cops got called again
oh no and so that's the one i don't like
irvine cops
what's wrong with irvine cops they're
really tough i don't like irvine pranks
i don't like i just don't like these
pranks that are like there's
that have a victim and people don't sign
up for it and it causes all kinds of
chaos and there's like
old ladies having heart attacks on the
bench like this is a very traumatic
inducing
trauma-inducing prank yeah like the uber
driver he's just like you're wasting his
time and money
because he could be picking somebody
else up right now to make money i also
heard
i don't know if this is true i don't
know if you know this but like what i
heard like when the cops got
called like guns were drawn on the uber
driver
too or something like that yeah i read
that part too
the guns are drawn on the uber the car
in general yeah
wow they had to like they spent a couple
minutes figuring out the driver was not
involved
with the the the actual problem yeah so
they're saying that that second time
that they you're right you're right that
they ordered the driver out of the car
at gunpoint
and then that's when cops arrived to
that scene
and then they were like i don't know
that's traumatizing [ __ ] bro oh yeah man
it's like if you're skating right now
oh we did we were we had guns out for a
skit for being youtubers
yes we did have an experience like that
you guys were waving guns around outside
no but hold on there was no innocent
people involved no no
i'm not sure we weren't faking a crime
that's the thing it's just not nuts that
cops pulled guns on you that's all i'm
saying well what was that we were faking
a crime
we were giving people we were robbing
them and giving them money we're robbing
david
yeah we were faking we weren't faking
the crime on the public that's what i
meant yeah
we looked like the film crew like there
was like 10 of us there was 10 cameras
with big
microphone pole we had we had looked
like an amateur film crew yeah amateur
we looked like a college film group
student film bro student film student
film bro i had the police calling me
when out we were shooting a music
video we were beating up uh the the
theme of the video was like we were
we were an [ __ ] gang that was like
beating up the guy that was selling
oranges on the freeway and then he gets
his revenge and like murders us all but
anyways we're beating him up we're doing
the scene we had the [ __ ] big ass
cameras there too
police got calling us police rolled up
we're like dude this camera right there
you know what i'm saying and we took
pictures with the cops and it was it was
cool
it was insane with us it was like oh cam
came in unmarked cars
yeah but they saw the cameras but they
still pulled out with guns
yeah sounds like the danger boy shoe
where the cop rolled up he's like oh
yeah we get a picture
he's a fan yeah that was fun do you
remember when you were standing in front
of my house at like
four or five in the morning and cops
rolled by and they're like hi bart
hi mark four or five in the morning yeah
the sun wasn't even up yet the sun
wasn't even it took me a second to hear
it no the cop rolled by me where
me and joe gonna take a flight somewhere
so that's how it's like four or five in
the
morning
and then the cop just reversed back all
the way in the street
and then he's like hey bart okay hey
what's up man that was it no
no conversation so i get out and i see
him talking to a cop and a cop
is never in my neighborhood like at
three or four in the morning right so
i'm like
what do you know this dude like what
goes oh he was just a fan and i'm like
how did he even catch you because first
off it's dark as [ __ ] on my street
so like how did he even see barton yeah
i'm just standing there with my luggage
just
yeah and bart doesn't do pictures if
it's before the sun comes up
so bart's like respectfully i don't do
pictures yet so and that's why all he
said was high part
yeah yeah so anyway so these twins
they are each being charged with one
felony count of false imprisonment
affected by violence menace fraud or
deceit
and one misdemeanor count of falsely
reporting an emergency
oh so they're gonna be in jail for over
a year so they're saying that if the
brothers
are convicted on all counts they face a
maximum sentence of four years in prison
holy [ __ ] do you think that they're
gonna charge them as one person
and they both get the same thing if they
show up wearing the same thing yeah
maybe or or if they get four years one
guy serves two the other they'll be
[ __ ] up
like one rat's on the other one
they could split the time up funny
because i i had two twin friends
that they used to go like they would
switch each other to go to different
classes
yeah because like for whatever reason
twins are weird man they got that weird
connection like where like i feel like
if you if you if you
scratch tickle one's ear the other one's
like ah you know really
like finishing a sentence yeah yeah
cause they they do
say that thing when a twin is hurt or
one dies and they're apart that they
actually
feel it yeah damn so i wonder if one's
getting laid the other one's like oh oh
[ __ ] brother come on you knew i was
gonna go out today
you know i'm a fighter pilot i'm like oh
god damn i'm coming
i'm coming my brother's getting a
[ __ ] again
and the other guy's like miss smash he's
like come in for landing
yeah they're just mixed completely
i know i always none of you guys have
ever dated a twin
um i'm curious like what would that be
i've said twins
to a friend before then and then give
him a high five oh so the friend got the
twins
the friend got the twins yeah oh you
didn't even get one no no he was
he was he was with a twin and so i had
to say twins
i met someone who's uh recently
like well they got with a triplet
but she moved in with his brother
but then got with his brother wait what
like a roommate
like she was there yeah yeah and then
she got with his
brother and then their triplets and then
they all do business together but
there's three of them there's three of
them yeah yeah three
females three males three males it's my
friend's sister
okay so she she moved in with a with a
guy
she moved in with a guy right yeah and
finds out he's
he's a triplet like he is yeah so her
name
was the triplet and she got with one of
our the other the roommate's brother
yeah i don't wanna hear about three guys
i don't hear about three girls
yeah yeah but when i see uh twin porn
i always wonder why is this incest but
it's still so hot
twins are pretty down man it is pretty
hot you wouldn't get off on seeing two
twin dudes uh
suck each other off that is pretty gross
to jason momoa's no it's kind of really
one because it's like one jason mamoa
it's like a clone
two casey chans yes okay but you just my
own twin
would you be jealous if you're involved
wait but then that's weird yeah it's
weird no
no no but it's your clone it's my clone
yeah oh your clones twin
yeah what so it's like
it's they ended up being triplets if
it's like the prestige and i can kill my
twin after
oh what if the gun's closer to him right
oh [ __ ] yeah
you'd be down for two jason mamoas at
once as long as they don't touch each
other right no
what you don't want them i don't want
two dicks that's too many dicks
wow jason momoa dicks yeah and he
demands and you have so many holes but
what about jason mama by himself
they don't all need to be filled up at
the same time
well you have so many you're not trying
to be a turkey
we though this is fun though oh i'm
having fun
you're trying to be well tiff you're not
trying to be rotisserie tiff
oh no no no thank you just just in
conversation
that's it rotisserie tiff i don't know
man
you know i i grew up thinking i'm sure
i've told you guys this before but i
grew up thinking i really did have a
long-lost twin
because i have a photo physical evidence
that i have a twin
what my mom swears it's just like some
crazy like
80s effect or 90s effect of a photo
where they just superimposed me
with me my dress overlaps
the other girl's dress i'm like i have a
twin i know i have a twin
yo that's f you creep me out with that
bro that's a crazy story
i got the chips yeah because i believe
you
it's true is it a really old photo no
it's a i have a
physical photo of another person that
looks just like you from the early 90s
there's two others from the early 90s
listen
to tiffany it is my baptism okay it's my
baptism day
and they hired a photographer and so he
was taking pictures the video recorded
and everything
and so one of those photos they thought
they were gonna be fancy and use
me again and put two like there's two of
me right next to each other
i have to post this photo this is before
like photoshop
was did you know the digital era of
photoshop you seen this picture i've
seen the
photo yeah are you a baby at a glance it
looks like she has a twin i'm not i'm
one years old
and the poses are different from two
people it's not just a superimposed so
one person's like this the other
person's like
yeah and then and then the reason why i
believe that i do have a twin for so
long
is because my dress of one girl like
like for example if it's
us two then like her hand or foot or
something is underneath like
this girl's dress you know what i mean
yeah yeah what if you had a siamese twin
oh and she got cut off oh you could've
had a siamese twin wait isn't that like
not pc
anymore or something oh to say siamese
oh
but there's a siamese person here yes
that's true that's true siam is the
original name of thailand oh i didn't
know that
yeah because there's no siam country oh
it's tight
i had never really stopped to think like
where does that come from these twins
because in the circus there was a uh
like a attached twin
that came from siam so it's a siamese
twin
so it's like the so are you offended tim
now yeah that's how it goes sometimes
because they told me to be offended so i
am i learned
i learned why i should be offended by it
so now i am oh okay well
yeah how dare you now no but no she was
just saying she was saying what if she
had a half thai
twin is what we were talking about
that's exactly what i said yeah
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store
below and you can round around yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you